this show is brought to you by datsusara
go to dsgear.com and check out their
extremely high quality functional gear
that's made with hemp textiles they have
bags geese rash guards and much much
more including the the infamous fanny
pack go to dsgear.com right now and use
cobra joey to get five percent off and
they sponsor ebi
on september [ __ ] 11th i think on a
sunday at the orpheum theater they are
the true [ __ ] sponsors of ebi so
that's awesome they're they're the ebi
and they're they they also could
probably be the matt therapy thing
they're a great company dsgear.com
codeword joey show is also brought to
you by onnit.com go to onyx.com and use
codewordchurch to get 10 off all of
their amazing optimization products like
alpha brain new mood shrimp tech immune
and shroom tech sport
oh [ __ ]
it's wednesday [ __ ] night
lee siyat
barcena
the church of what's happening now
oh [ __ ]
it's going down [ __ ] kick that
mule lee banging it bam bam bang
blow up some speakers [ __ ] i want
fire coming out of those [ __ ] things
oh [ __ ]
there you go lee
it's a beautiful evening here in
southern california it's like [ __ ] 80
degrees
it's going to be hot again tomorrow who
gives a [ __ ] what's happening willie
bustin what's up baby man thanks for
having me brother always what's going on
lee syed you sexy [ __ ] you i had
a fun day i am
i was it was funny i came in i was like
what do you think about doing a gravity
ball and you weren't a big fan
no because you have a hard time with
this regular [ __ ] bomb
[ __ ] for nothing you have a hard time
with this your face turned red before
you were sweating your legs was sweating
everything sweats the bongs are [ __ ]
crazy this is tremendous that's why you
[ __ ] hit them what's happening willy
boy cena good brother man i'm just
enjoying the scene man you guys are
this is laid back this is
i think all interviews should be like
this
all interviews smell this good it's not
even [ __ ] into me it's a conversation
yeah i know yeah it goes
i'm happy you're here tonight because
one of the things uh a lot of comedians
young comedians listen to this [ __ ]
and i didn't you know it's scary really
if i tell you this like i didn't even
think about it until 15 years in
like i had a notebook and i would write
the joke right and that was it there was
no tag
there was nothing for 15 years i got
over on just energy
and just driving in a car to the comedy
store and thinking about what i was
going to say right and sometimes it
would go my way and sometimes it would
well i think most of the time it you
know it went your way brother
but it's crazy how
15 years ago you know about eight nine
years ago i started writing right and i
go i like this this is interesting [ __ ]
i started writing a blog on myspace and
and also i said man i forgot all about
this story maybe i should say this on
stage and while you're saying the story
you remember another story
and it's just [ __ ] amazing so
i i like to sit down now with a notebook
you know people coming to the shows yeah
you want to give them their money's
worth you know
and i've always been a fan of your uh
like i remember used to show up to
[ __ ]
a bar with a notebook and then go what
is he crazy it's a [ __ ] ball why does
he have a notebook why is he looking at
his notes and then i would go up there
i'd bomb
no and you'd go up there and kill and i
go this is why you have to have a
notebook so i started carrying around a
little note
the only other option i use on this
thing is when i get an idea there's a
memo pad now on the iphone tremendous
you can write the [ __ ] note in there
and then remind yourself later
but i swear to god willie i [ __ ] got
rid of so i've gotten rid of more good
jokes than most people have written just
off the top laziness being in bed at
night and [ __ ] cracking up with the
sleep apnea mask on
and going that was so funny i remember
that [ __ ] in the morning and
nothing's there in the moment no they're
farting if you don't write it down man
it's literally a fart in the wind bro
it's gone since day one you were a
writer like that you sat down and well
you you know um
i i uh
i always when i was a young young you
know we were young comics man coming up
i used to watch the tonight show right
and i used to hear about these guys uh
the gary chandlings of the world those
guys were ahead of us way ahead of us
and i used to hear about how they would
write and i would hear how seinfeld
would write and uh so that's what got me
started and then i kind of had an
evolution like you you know i went
through an evolution and i i think you
don't go through it unless you do write
because
it's funny we were talking the other day
and you were going man well i started
out writing a joke
and then from joke i went to bits and
then from bits i went into stories right
he told me
that's the evolution man because i
remember uh writing jokes you know
you know like uh you know one line jokes
and the premise set up punch
prema set up punch and then uh and then
after a while it got corny to me man i
go man there's got to be a little bit
more to this so i started kind of
embellishing or or or extending the
story a little bit more i'm saying well
what what you know started
asking myself it was a lot of trial and
error so within a lot of that trial and
error and like you
i bombed and failed way more than i
succeeded
and then and that's how i i
i started writing all the time because i
i realized it was uh like it was like a
like a batting percentage you know
only three out of ten jokes would work
and for in order for me to have a
material i'd have to write a lot a lot
of material had to fail for me to have
material that that would succeed or even
have a nice little new chunk for me to
have a nice new chunk i had a like a
maybe a half hour of garbage
so anyways brother yeah that's that's
that's how
you know
and and you know what having kids man
having kids to me is what made me right
because i i knew how to keep feeding
these [ __ ] so you know if i
didn't keep getting work somewhere you
know wherever uh uh that was that was
also motivated for me joy it's funny how
you said something before and i thought
completely different
you said before that you know how many
coming tonight's your appearances did
you have with jay leno i had 11 11
that a lot of comics looked at you
differently because you were on the
tonight show and you had to say jokes
now let me tell you you know me you know
i'm [ __ ] out of my mind yeah yeah
yeah
to me
till this day
even with that [ __ ] guy on there now
oh i have nothing against jimmy fallon i
like jimmy fallon
i'll still
see who's going to be on the tonight
show right so i can tape it and not tape
it because to me that's the best the
comic is going to do
i swear to god in my mind
that's when i when i watch the tonight
show and i see a comic not do well and
the next time i see him i'm going to
smack him all right and he knows this
lee knows that we've talked about eliza
going on there one night and blew it up
and i was happy the next day because
jesus christ finally
somebody took it to the next level on
the [ __ ] tonight show you know what
i'm saying so when i don't watch the
tonight show to me
it's
the six minutes that every comic should
dream of that's my world that's my world
you get one shot at writing six minutes
spotless clean
with your real point of view
clean though yeah but they also edit man
they had it yeah yeah yeah
the tough part is that they they have
control of of uh of your uh your
material because the reality is joy when
you're performing for the tonight show
you're it's it's a it's a corporate gig
because you're performing for those
little sponsorships you know for the the
chevrolets and the bmws and the atm t's
company because if you offend uh the
show you offend them because they're
paying for advertisement so it's really
the biggest corporate gig you're ever
gonna do
and being at that it's a corporate gig
you're [ __ ] man because you gotta be
within these boundaries and you're not
allowed to be free and you're you're a
big fan of lenny bruce and i am and i i
read a book man where i was really happy
it was the last chapter where lenny
bruce was talking about doing the
tonight show with jack parr back in the
day this is before johnny carson and he
talked about
how much he hated
doing the like he didn't like doing the
tonight show because he felt so
contrived and he says uh i love doing
one hour you know i love doing my albums
you know when he did his albums and he
did his one hours in theaters and he was
free and he's
you're free man
you know you're your own director your
own writer you you you get to say
whatever the [ __ ] you want to say and
you can't do that on on on the tonight
show but and anyways man i i know there
was there was comics because i you know
you hear the you hear the gossip within
our world man oh yeah willie barcena
he's he's corny or he's not edgy or
whatever but man bro you can go you know
to me there was a lot of um
you know there was a lot of a lot of
haters man because if you you know i
don't care you if you go back to sam
kinnison who's one of the craziest
[ __ ] out there watch him on the
tonight show he's got a suit on
he's got a suit on and a tie man you
know you watch
richard pryor another guy he's got a
suit on and a tie and doing and and it's
so you're you're it's a tough gig man
and uh and to me i felt that uh that uh
within
uh the comics man they were like oh
really you know well really uh you know
doesn't doesn't have a soul kind of
thing you know because
it's very contrived man
it's so funny how
i have this crazy sense of [ __ ]
thinking
but when comics would get things i
didn't have those things
so i could never judge their experience
honestly even even when i would let
myself start saying something like who
the [ __ ] are you when
when are you going to be on the tonight
show what are you going to have a show
time you know what i'm saying like i was
always honest with you
when you go to clicks you know like when
you go to a comedy open mic for example
right there's three little clicks right
there's one click you go and somebody
will ask you what do you think about
[ __ ] amy schumer on this
and you just sit back and watch how much
effort these comics
put into hating and i'm just saying amy
schumer i'm not i'm just saying it
people at home it could be uh could be
anybody could be pablo it could be
myself yeah you know when they
once you hit a certain level of
mainstream yeah it does something to
comedians that jar is there not to me i
i listen man that's the that's the
evolution
that means that you're up there you're
up there with the corporate people
you're playing golf you're going to
president [ __ ] whatever
what do you want me to do you want me to
hate you because of that
you want me to hate you because of that
that all started at a [ __ ] comedy
club yeah you had the same dream i had
you just took it in a different [ __ ]
direction i'm happy for you no you know
man there's a lot of those people that
we don't think
are funny yeah
we don't think they're funny yeah as
comedians like that dude don't even show
up into the improv what he does the last
two times he's bombed we've seen those
guys that have that mega celebrity and
they walk in dave chappelle always kicks
ass because they get on their feet from
i never saw that they chris rock they
would come in and go chris rocks here
the people would [ __ ] go crazy right
those guys never [ __ ] bomb you know
but there's guys from you know what they
were weak when they first started if you
if you
google some of their early sex oh no no
i'm talking about when they pop into
this oh no oh yeah yeah yeah
no no yeah now
they walk on water now yeah yeah that's
what i'm saying yeah listen everybody
dies a slow death yeah i don't ever you
know the the funniest people in l.a are
the people like i used to go to acting
classes and people would ask me stupid
questions then they come to the comedy
store they go to the improv
factory they watch me and they go how
long have you been doing this
and i got like nine years and then three
weeks later i'd see him and then i got
on stage last week and uh i got a show
here and i got an audition in montreal
and i've been doing it for them
and you look at them because they're
looking at you like going you've wasted
your time for nine years yeah but you're
looking at them going oh you're gonna
die a slow [ __ ] death you got nowhere
to go you're gonna [ __ ] your [ __ ]
pants in front of those people remember
we started these to be a lot more
contests yeah johnny walker
they had the nbc national comedy contest
it was this is and it wasn't televised
it wasn't like last comic standing right
right they came into a comedy club at 10
in the morning you had to get there by
nine sign your [ __ ] name
there'd be three [ __ ] jerk-offs
sitting there with a notepad yeah and
you went up there did it and then you
went home then they called you to come
back for that night's show
and then you went on to the regionals
the finals i've always thought that the
stupidest thing is to judge comics man
you know why it it's like having a
because everybody has a a different
personality and everybody likes
different things and it's almost like
putting up a rock band versus a country
a country band it's like well i like the
rock band that the rock band killed and
i didn't understand the country man well
it's what you liked man that's why i
don't think you can't judge khan i don't
like comedy in that sense yeah just
saying that yeah well you can't judge it
but don't you think if it was like let's
say it was like a comedy club here if
they just grabbed 300 people there'd be
some people who liked indie comedy
there'd be some people who like dirty
comedy so maybe
maybe could you just judge it based off
of laughter
well how they how they did judge him was
based off the left right
you know like i did
i was never a big contest guy
i didn't believe in them either like
they were when i first got into comedy
all these contests were happening and i
didn't think i was good enough so i
wouldn't go down there but there was an
amateur contest that i went to
and i ended up winning and they got me a
guest uh it got me a hosting gig right
right 50 a week 200 a month that ain't
bad when you first started right people
don't make money at all i was getting
two bills a month right from the [ __ ]
beginning
and then i moved to seattle and they
have that contest and to really get work
in the area they don't care about tape
or nothing they look at the numbers from
that contest
and i took a sixth and they told me as a
dirty comic you won't even get to the
semi-finals so for a dirty comic it was
good at that time for me i was really
dirty i didn't know what i was doing
but
when i came to la he called me again
and he goes i want you to do san
francisco now seattle had newspaper
reporters
and restaurant owners and movie theater
people
i can live with that right i could live
with that you know what san francisco
had
comics yeah
that was the mecca at the time right
robin williams started that
judging comics and i said i'm not
staying here
it's like you coming up to me and me
hugging you before the show lee how are
you gonna feel
if i'm one of the contestants and you're
standing there like all excited about
this contest but i walk in and willie's
the judge and and felipe is the other
judge and i give him a big a big hug and
i go let's go smoke pot later how do you
feel as a [ __ ] comic you're going to
go hang out why am i going on stage for
joey knows these [ __ ] guys that's how
it was up there right i was like are you
[ __ ] i'm sleeping on the beach really
i'm living in my car doing this contest
sleeping on the beach because the hotels
are 300 [ __ ] thoughts yeah i'm
sleeping on the beach dog i woke up
santa cruz saturday morning i swear to
god
i sat there with sand in my feet
i had to take a shower like a gym for 10
bucks yeah
and i go am i [ __ ] [ __ ]
am i [ __ ] stupid
what i'm at the comedy store tonight i
got a set if i want and sally cruz was
playing at the house of blues
i got in that [ __ ] car and i drove
home they kept calling me where are you
[ __ ] you
i'm gonna do your stupid [ __ ] contest
sell your cruises in town and i got 11
o'clock at the store and [ __ ]
[ __ ] getting judged by other comics
that are hugging it up and smoking dope
the promoter came up to me he goes
johnny weed
the dude who ran the [ __ ] thing was
like oh
yeah i know you got weed on you you have
to smoke me out before the night is over
you're the [ __ ] promoter you gotta
smoke me out you're [ __ ] all right
it's [ __ ] it's crazy how
it's like there's no other is there a
business that will uh compares to it at
all every [ __ ] business has the [ __ ]
side of it oh yeah yeah everybody's had
the [ __ ] side of it every business has
in the beginning everybody rapes you
you know everybody [ __ ] you in the ass
at any business whether you're an editor
a mechanic's helper right you know
they're paying you eight but they're
charging 22.50 for you
and laughing the whole way you know what
i'm saying i mean you're getting [ __ ]
the whole time but it's what you take
from the experience and what you learn
and what you know when we used to go to
latino night on a monday night right
right yeah you walk into latino like
there were people hanging from the
rafters 22.50
jamie gave you 25 bucks there was six
comics his budget was 150. what the [ __ ]
do you think there's 300 people in that
22.50 that's 2 000 in the room you get
his budget with you know ten dollars a
beer yeah he's making six thousand for
the [ __ ] night then mexicans are
going crazy on a [ __ ] monday night
and and where do you think that money
goes lee but you accept it because you
go you know what man i'm gonna start in
comic how lucky do you feel just to be
fortunate yeah to be in this position
but don't be too [ __ ] fortunate
they're not they're not you know when
they come up to you they say they love
you yeah you better [ __ ] love me
right you just made three grand off me
jumping up and [ __ ] down i'm not
saying they came to see me
but i'm part of the [ __ ] ensemble if
i was in a [ __ ] theater we all get
paid 62.50 right or wrong for a [ __ ]
performance so
i think what it might be
is like whenever you start somewhere or
something they remember you so if you if
you go to all these clubs and you let
them
take advantage of you with money it must
be hard as you get older to be like no
now you actually have to pay me my money
because they're so used to not paying
you
well you got representation fighting for
you yeah you got every you know it's
really weird when you're out there
fighting for yourself
and all of a sudden an agent pops in
your life right and he calls you with a
number and you're like wait a second
i did that same gig three years ago for
500 bucks how'd you get me 5 000
you get pissed off for two minutes yeah
you're like i put nine thousand dollars
in that guy's pocket now you figure out
what's the truth it's the weirdest game
man and it's a hotel and there's a car
involved and two years yeah and a
hundred dollars for food yeah and you're
like that [ __ ] gig paid 500 two years
ago
yeah because you didn't have
representation no it's cause you know
here it goes man you call up the place
and you go hey i'm funny and then go oh
you're funny all right so then they give
you a contract like the contract sucks
dick right but then a couple years
passed by now an agent calls hey he's
really funny oh he is
wait you know what i mean it's a
different story man it's uh
it's such an evolution like i sit back
first of all
i did something with my life i stuck
with something which was the most
important thing of life
sticking with something yeah you know
you see these people that keep moving
around every day when i wake up i have a
notebook that i just write what i feel
i gotta go to jiu-jitsu today i gotta
meet willie
i gotta do this and at the end i always
write i'm very happy that i did
something with my life nice man that's
really cool
because
anything you're gonna do that you have a
dream of doing you know look at the
stones okay look at the [ __ ] rolling
stones man they're each worth 250
[ __ ] million dollars i don't know how
much they're getting in palm springs
those tickets are 250 a piece they got
to be walking out of there with six
hundred thousand dollars
they paid their dues
they take that money without no guilt at
all right right they've been doing this
for 40 [ __ ] years and you as the
consumer have to recognize that
you have to go wow i'm coming to see
these guys that have really been doing
this for 40 years i've been i've had six
jobs in three years
these guys been doing the same [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and that's how i i don't know i i'm very
fortunate that somewhere i got stupid
because for years i kept saying i'm
never gonna do nothing you know
somewhere along the line i got stupid
when i got into comment or if i get into
this
i got to get dirty right because
everything else i would do really was
for money right everything else i would
do yeah how much is it to cook nine
dollars an hour really and also you're
there a week and you're like what did i
make 360 after taxes is 280
i could sell an eight ball and make this
right and nothing lasted but when i got
into comedy i had nothing i had no wife
i lost everything i had my kid i had i
already had a felony i had already gone
through all this [ __ ] so i said listen
let me dive into this
but i know that i got to change my
lifestyle yeah like there's no couch
there's no bait there's nothing i have
to get into this you have to go out
every night you know right once i saw
that
it changed me like i was like i'm in
and still i wouldn't write i would just
write my goals i would write what jokes
i wanted to do and what all this [ __ ]
like that i never really had a closer
but then i came to l.a and i started
watching different guys
and there's people that are good writers
but they're writing [ __ ] right you
know what i'm saying yeah they're great
writers and it's great for the minute
and it takes years to see that like a
comic because you know what you're doing
and and if you're any comic that's good
you always think you're doing [ __ ] like
the material i got now ain't working
meanwhile people are [ __ ] falling off
what are you talking about right i don't
like that [ __ ] joke i just do it
because my kid
the [ __ ]
people are dying it's a good joke we
never think we have the good [ __ ] you
know
so it's really weird how
the process just of comedy just
you just fall in love with it yeah
and even though you're getting kicked in
the air and even though you're having
all these problems in your personal life
because at some point in comedy in the
beginning you get some turmoil that
that's life testing you right it's like
when you quit smoking you know when your
uncle dies and you're at the funeral
pond everybody's smoking cigarettes you
know what i'm saying this all right well
my uncle died so i started smoking again
you know what i'm saying it's comedy
like i remember [ __ ] living in a car
yeah and taking showers at the gym but
going i'm still going to do my spot
tonight right you know i remember being
in jail for 30 days
and while i was in jail writing jokes
and going i can't wait to get out so i
get on [ __ ] stage
like these were all part of my life in
the early beginning that somebody else
would have just i ain't doing this no
more why am i doing this [ __ ] what it's
challenging brother i i think uh you
know what you said as far as uh
um uh stories things that happen to you
like what you're telling me where you
you know you're you're literally
suffering man you don't know you're
suffering out of time
people when you're suffering you don't
know you're going through it because
you're going through it you know it's
once you pass it you go you go damn i
was suffering but when you're going
through it
you you don't but
some those are some of the best bits
that you can write about whatever you
went through you know whatever whatever
was kicking you in the ass
uh uh you know is are your best bits
you know i mean that's that's what i've
through two decades of writing okay
the best tip i can tell a young comic
out there is i just don't write funny
man when i write i don't write funny at
all
i write a story some [ __ ] that happened
to me and i just i just write it out
you know
and then what i do is
leave it alone because
if i read it i'm going to start crying
you know if it's a
my kid not talking to me and i remember
the story where he didn't want to talk
to me and it hurt or or my wife leaving
or whatever man you know what i mean
whatever happened uh or something where
i was dreaming you always brought it to
the stage really yeah you always do that
you believe in i believe in it also yeah
that's when i started getting real
laughs yeah i started showing my pain
and what i went through and whatever the
[ __ ] yeah people love to see somebody
else [ __ ] dying like in a way like
yeah well you know what i think i think
joey i think they the the audience
because we're all flawed man and i think
when they see another person on stage
that's flawed and and us we're
we're you know uh humorous man you know
which i think there's there's joke
tellers and there's humorous and i think
of us as humorous because we tell them a
story you know i mean
and uh and and when they see
you know no as much as everybody wants
to put up a front
a lot of people we're on on this earth
and a lot of us have had some trials and
tribulations and a lot of us have been
there man where there's been some pain
but we know how to uh push it down so
when we're on stage and and and they see
a comic they can relate now and now they
don't feel alone they don't feel like
they're alone on this planet where you
want to [ __ ] hang yourself you look
at and you go [ __ ]
that guy went through the same [ __ ] i
went through and he's laughing about it
so i'm gonna laugh at my [ __ ] so i think
that's the connection that we make uh uh
uh when we're telling stories that we're
telling you know i i i tell the story
man where you know for years it was it
was it was um used to bother me man and
i didn't know how to make it funny you
know because when i was a kid i just get
[ __ ] up by my mom we we grew up
getting [ __ ] up man i got hit
hard i got hit with others
it was just two sisters bro
they're both older than
i'm in the middle
and my mom used to [ __ ] us up man and i
remember talking to like everybody talks
about you know your mom [ __ ] you up
but man i was on stage a couple years
ago and i just and i wasn't talking
about man yeah my mom used to beat me no
not like that man i got
i got into details right and i said man
now that my mom's old you know uh she's
like a kid you know she's not she she
she's uh she's all there don't get me
wrong it's not you know but she's she's
uh
she argues with me you know what i mean
like an older person it's almost like
and i feel like
sometimes i feel like putting up pulling
out a whip and [ __ ] her up bro and
telling her what she used to tell me hey
get your hands out the way do you know
what i mean i mean yeah that when i tell
that on stage about you know when when
you just sit when you put it by itself
man this guy's talking about whipping
his own mom when you leave it like that
yeah it's not funny but when you hear
the whole story man and you can share
this with audience or anybody that got
hit when they were a kid and they can
see this man i think there's almost a
sense of uh
it's a sense of therapy bro i i believe
you know i mean i'm not there to [ __ ]
save anybody's life or anything like
that don't get me wrong but i think at
times us unwillingly we
we uh we there might be some uh therapy
within those within that humor for us as
a comedian for us and the audience for
me
i love
you know on tuesday nights now i go to a
bar willy right because i'm sick and
tired of performing on a tightrope right
it's a great job
but it's not the way we were brought up
and to get the maximum value out of me i
i can't walk on a tightrope all the time
right you know i'm not the type of dude
that could sit down and go okay
what did i see today on the news that
was
funny all right i saw something
the [ __ ] uh the shootout at the gas
station you know
although there was a lady trying to get
gas and she's in the [ __ ] passion you
see
and these people are having a shootout
and she's in the passenger seat though
and she dropped and you can see the
bullet holes but then i don't know what
happened the baby yelled and i went into
the other room
okay
you write that down right it's a nice
old lady getting shot okay if i sit
there for two hours nothing's gonna
happen right but if i'm on stage
talking about guns
and all of a sudden
by mistake and by the grace of god
that thought crosses my mind
really i could run with it for 20
minutes and it's a bit
now let's say i tape it lee tapes it
guess what i'll never say it like that
again the other day when you said that
it's just like acting you got to feel it
oh my god like [ __ ] firecrackers went
off in my head
yeah because it's the same thing with
acting yeah with acting you got to get
triggers
if you when i was a kid i went to that
anthony robbins workbook what's his name
anthony highlands what's that no name
robinson tony robbins i worked for
subaru and as a as a group subaru of
america paid for us and we all went to
denver for two days and sat with them we
didn't have to walk on calls or nothing
but if i remember anything from that
workbook
he spoke a lot about triggers as a
salesman
like how you know you could be talking
to somebody and then go to that place
and just [ __ ] march him down
and sometimes when you look at your best
sets right you're in a coma yeah you're
gonna come
your best sets i mean you're in a
[ __ ] coma yeah when you don't give a
[ __ ] that's why i like those open mics
because i have to not give a [ __ ] for a
few weeks
to give a [ __ ] yeah
the open mics are a weird situation
though because like i i i've only been
into a few i went to the time that you
hosted at the store
and i've been there these few times okay
let's get something straight okay
there's open mics and there's open mics
open mic 101 is willie's room
i used to do in new york
it's a bar
with a tv
and just by the grace of god they have a
two-foot stair
that will as animals is a stage
okay we will take five feet of that and
use it as a stage
because in the beginning you're not
gonna walk into the improv yeah
i don't care who owns it i don't care
who you dick you're gonna suck you're
not gonna walk in there and you
personally will find out years later you
don't want to walk in there anyway
so you find these bars
where
they have no commitment to comedy
they have no commitment to comedy
they walk in and there's a [ __ ] fat
[ __ ] from new york on the stage
and they go oh my god we didn't know you
were having comedy tonight we just
wanted to have martinis yeah
okay so they sit down to talk about
martinis and how miserable their life is
okay like really that's what women go
out for at night i'm having problems
with danny i think i think he's eating
oxycodones again let's go out for a
martini and they go out and get drunk
and nothing got [ __ ] handled but the
beauty of it is
if you could convince those ladies
and not by going hey hey lady i'm up
here talking yeah yeah if you could
convince those two [ __ ] to turn
around and look at you and pay attention
that's how you judge in those days
yeah okay so they were
unpremeditated comedy people
and you had it and and here's what
here's the magic the magic where you i
think where you got your your your you
know your skills whereas i was in in
getting those ladies
or the group whoever came in
to look at you and not do it in a way
where you pissed them off yeah you
pissed them now
now it's all downhill but if you were
able to kind of judo judo their
conversation towards you it's brilliant
you know and it's like and it's just
like you say it could be a simple hey
girls night out and then yeah you know
and they might one of them might say
something might one of them might reveal
something she might say yeah well lisa's
here's we all took lisa out and then you
all started going lisa yeah you know
you just keep going there so that's an
open mic 101 that's where there's no
commitment to comedy okay when i call
you up leon on tuesday go late
sarah silverman is at the stinky onion
on friday night i just bought three
tickets for us me you and paula
okay all week we're thinking about sarah
silverman
so we're premeditated comedy we walk in
there
that's the comedy where they're waiting
they're already waiting for willie
they're already waiting for joey i go in
and if i say my dick's got a rim about
it
okay so you can't really
there's two types of comedy there's two
types of comedy
okay but to get really good at this
comedy
you gotta go through this comedy here
is it and it's brutally
because there's 16 different types
there's that one but really comedy 101
is i'm wrong i'm
[ __ ] wrong comedy 101 is when you go
on stage in front of 15 comics that pay
the dollar for a drink at the comedy to
do comedy that's comedy 101 right that's
[ __ ] brutality that's where you go
home every night and you look at the
[ __ ] razor blade and you look at the
tub and the song
you're [ __ ] that is brutal that is
[ __ ] comedy
commando
there's only one thing that bust you out
of that right like a [ __ ] savior
those guys that's like that that's below
hell
if you judge it that way okay where they
go
and and every once in a while they get
eight people
but beside that it's all comedians every
night from six to ten or from ten to one
or from eleven to two and then here's
where the it's tough for some young
comedians
uh you know enjoy say you walk in those
rooms and there's 15 comics
maybe eight of those comics are a group
they're friends and they'll laugh at
each other's jokes
and when they get a real audience
that joke sucks balls bro and now
they're now there's like you know
it was detrimental instead of being
something positive for a comic it
actually took you a step back because
your friends are there trying to trying
to be your buddy instead of telling you
the truth that that material sucked
we all started comedy 101
and then by the grace of god you meet
somebody at comedy 101 who says hey i
run a room on tuesday another 10.
and you got to come in there first of
all you got to come in there some nights
and some nights or whatever town you're
living they got that [ __ ] gamer and
that way yeah yeah you know what i'm
saying you got to follow the lakers if
you think yeah you have to start on time
because you have another set that
doesn't work you're not going to do
comedy while the lake is on on [ __ ]
tv so these are all the lessons you
learned and then somebody's like uh leo
go lee come on down to my room but the
other lesson you don't learn this is the
show starts at 10. but you're going to
go up a [ __ ] one in front of six
people yeah and they're drunk and
they're drunk this is something that you
[ __ ] die for six months doing this
and going when am i gonna get a 9 30
spot at a [ __ ] bar like that all
right and then eventually you at that
bar you're at that bar you're at you
know it's like you're trying to bust out
of this league
and then you get in with a booker but
guess what he books
bars
six in a row you know
the guy from seattle or triple triple
dribble
you know they were all over the [ __ ]
country where they book you know they
book a hotel lounge yeah here you
thinking you're playing at the garden
for the 2 000 people i'm going on the
road and [ __ ] what road and all of a
sudden you get a note don't curse
because they're mormons
you know this is [ __ ] outrageously
this is all right but this is how you
learn
nuts and bolts yeah you gotta get your
ass kicked this is how you learn
adjustment yeah this is how you learn
how to go into one room and there's 80
people and the next night there's six
yeah the next night there's seven and
the owner's like man you got a good
crowd yeah last week there was two
[ __ ]
you know you're like what
this is [ __ ] the evolution of it and
then you meet somebody and they go hey
what are you doing next week i need an
opener in some [ __ ] bum [ __ ] town
right and now they pay you 150 in a
hotel room and you get five drink
tickets oh my god when you get those
drink tickets you think you're the
[ __ ] king
you're at the bar looking for a [ __ ]
with that buck 50 burn
i'm one of the comedians of [ __ ]
so that's [ __ ] up though because you
always talk about how slimy comedians
are but you're my my original question
was going to be how do you know when to
stop doing open mics but it's obviously
people hire you yeah but you have to be
but now you have to be friendly with
people who might be douche bags just
because you want gigs well there's two
different ways you have people like
willie that come up you go no i think
you're funny
come to my room on tuesday night
and then willie would give you 40 bucks
and you got a [ __ ] burrito
you got your [ __ ] burrito too dawg i
always got that [ __ ] too i bring
the hunger to that club you wait all day
for that [ __ ] burrito tell them i
remember jerry bedknop jerry ben
uh for those of you if anybody's not
familiar with jerry bednav was uh in
that 40 year old virgin yeah good guy
plays the indian plays the indian and
then jay would always i don't know for
whatever reason he would always get the
burrito but he would always take it to
go to go yeah yeah they didn't even tell
you
when you got off stage there was a
burrito to go that's more than the forty
dollars okay
because that's a meal that's it you got
half of that that night
after that for breakfast like a soldier
you could use your 40 bucks for other
things like cigarettes and
alcohol
[ __ ] narcotics
you know it's uh do you ever
i think that people who me
miss that evolution
uh
really
don't get the full
circle of this career yeah well you know
what um i think something that's hurting
young comics today
is this is because it wasn't around when
we were started which is called uh a
bring bring bring bring your shows
like you can go on stage but if you
bring people you heard of this right
bringer shows you well we didn't have
bringer shots i had them in new york
when they went back to new york in 94.
oh okay bro for every person you brought
you gotta admit it
but yeah
yeah you have no idea well that took a
while for that to get here i was in
colorado and nothing was like that that
the bookers would say you know if you
want free tickets let me know i would be
embarrassed to ask people to come watch
me in those days right so i wasn't going
to tell nobody but when i went to new
york in 93 it was an education
because the comic strip and all those
places they let you go up oh yeah you
want to go up and go come on down and
see me
lee you get so excited you go down the
guy's like i'm gonna hit this guy's sick
bump into this guy my name is whatever
i'm the manager but talk to this guy and
also when you talk to this young college
kid
and he goes what night do you want to
do he's like i'm going to do tuesday
night the 18th you want to do the 5 30
show the 6 30 show the 7 30 show like i
want to do the 7 30 show okay and listen
it gives you an envelope me and there's
40 [ __ ] tickets
and he's like you got to sell these at
10 bucks a piece
and keep five for yourself i ate for
yourself so you always 80 bucks that
night
or you don't go up
[ __ ] like that lately
yeah and i would just pay the 80.
you know what i'm saying i would just
pay the 80 and sell the give away the
tickets
to [ __ ] as a sales thing or something
like that i swear to god i would be too
[ __ ] embarrassed i would just pay the
80 and go on stage
that's how crazy i [ __ ] was that's
not a bad deal though no it was hardly i
mean but i would never going to sell the
tickets and then they had the other
shows the only guy that put me up in
those days without people
was the guy at the new york comedy club
i went back to new york for nine
i got him yeah yeah yeah yeah he used to
wear the toupee yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but the other one the one on 78th
street the one to call the boston
something no that's on fourth street but
there was one on 78th street that i'm
off of broadway and one night i did a
spot there and i brought
10 people from my hometown
and this is when cocaine was [ __ ]
huge in my hometown and they all came
and were doing coke and they were
[ __ ] tipping the bar 10 to 10 bucks
apiece but i'll never forget that one of
my friends at that time was a cop
and he was with all his childhood
buddies
and i looked at him one time and he was
[ __ ] up he had coke all over his shirt
but he was standing there with his leg
on the bar and his badge and his gun was
sticking out you could see the ring
around his nose and i'm like no you
gotta wipe your nose
like this was a long [ __ ] time ago
and
they drank so much
that the owner came over to me goes you
always have a spot here just bring these
animals back and i couldn't figure it
out like they clogged the bathroom
that's when chris masili was the doorman
remember him he owns uh
uh uh
gotham's now he owns gotham's oh yeah
that's when chris masili was he was oh
my god
he had a full set of hair i'm going to
ask him i see him in september i go to
new york in september but that's what
that hustle was lee yeah lee that was a
hustler in new york you just weren't
going to get on stage you had to show up
with [ __ ] in those days so i
learned then like it was in a way it
taught me a little bit
new york that nine-month experience in
new york and i was still reading the
judy carter book yeah and writing her
jokes like that like right yeah what
pisses you off the ten things that give
you anger at that level
those nine months in new york i wasn't
sure about comedy bro i was using comedy
as a way of getting out of the criminal
thing but i was still
you know i just got out of prison so i
was doing comedy but not really it was
like my first year and a half in jiu
jitsu i would only go once a week
in those days i would get on stage two
times a month right but then when i went
to new york
all that little hustle in new york got
me a little excited but there was a bar
called your old triple-n
and i went in there one night and i saw
john leguizamo
at midnight
and bro it clicked
it clicked well whatever because i
always thought that willie barcena just
went on a tonight show
and did eight minutes of material
afterwards
bombing with notes with notes working
out and my whole vision came
two weeks later i was on my way to
colorado i said i don't need the
suffering i get spots in colorado
without showing up with 10 [ __ ]
all the time there's not as much cocaine
in my face every time i go to new york
to do a spot i'd stop at a spot and get
a package right in colorado i can't do
that right i really focused when i went
to colorado but it was because of that
experience in new york that opened my
[ __ ] eyes to what how i had to act
like funny how we all because i i had
the same experience when i saw damon
wayans back in the day where'd you start
right here in the club what club
oh
um
what was the first time comedy act
theater on crenshaw 43rd jesus christ
yeah with uh chris tucker man i used to
give i used to pick up chris tucker he
had an apartment um
uh near the 101 of uh of vine and chris
used to call me up because uh he didn't
even have a car man
and uh and and and it was him
uh dial highly was the host
he was a young comic uh joe torrey guy
tori wasn't even on the main show
yeah it was the first show and segments
who did the comedy actor it belonged to
the sweet dick willy no
michael williams michael and sharon
williams now who was the black actor
that was and do the right thing oh oh oh
oh that died baby's kids yeah yeah um
what what
yeah yeah that's that's the theater
that's a theater but he didn't own it he
was just a he was that was his house
basically as a comic but i was i started
with pierre all these cats i'm trying to
remember cats from those days you know
uh
but uh so
what's his name mark
mark haddish hanging with mr cooper was
that what's remember that show yeah
mark he's around yeah yeah he's on the
tv show yeah he's around i was getting
spots at the high bumped into her rouse
yeah and he goes they won't give me
spots at the store i go see the agostino
with the haha
so yeah gustino said he was going down a
couple nights a week and just working
out he was still really funny he was
funny yeah he's really funny listen 20
years in comedy
is 20 years in comedy something happens
to you
something happens to you yeah like you
said you're either gonna quit and fold
or get angry because there's guys that
we've been around uh uh have been around
as long as we have that you see them on
stage and they haven't progress i've
seen guys that i go this guy's just got
he has the same [ __ ] material from 20
years ago i mean from beginning to end i
mean you know i might not hurt anybody's
feelings
you know i'm going to see this guy
probably tomorrow
but a couple of these guys man and i'll
tease them i'll go i'll see these comics
and not don't i don't have the heart to
say so you know but i don't have the
heart to say nothing i can't say not no
more but have you seen it
friday night
i had a spot somewhere yeah
i'm not dead two minutes right
i hear yo
i look up
it's comedian i'm known for 15 years
yeah we used to do all the little
spanish rooms together right
did i think he was funny i thought he
had potential you know you look at these
guys and you're like that guy they all
did
yeah
yeah and they have material that you
laugh at and they have material you were
right there with them okay so i have the
right to say this
okay when i'm right there with them in
the trenches
right and now i'm somewhere else and
they're completely still in the [ __ ]
trenches you follow them saying to you
and i see that they work now but it's
not like it used to now they blame me on
things and [ __ ]
so it was like
it pisses me off like i get pissed off
because at the end of the day in the
back of my mind i'm a [ __ ] loser i
could flip this in a way and you
couldn't [ __ ] find a way to flip this
[ __ ] game for yourself you're still
hawking around two minutes there hello
how are you
how can i get a guest set yeah okay
absolutely not you're not gonna get up
here you're not gonna get up because i'm
first i'm working on an hour
and number two guess what the show's got
people in i worked hard all week on
twitter you just want to go in and blow
that [ __ ] rumor and i told you the
story five or six years ago he was on my
i hadn't seen him i wasn't at the store
anymore right so he said he was on this
international tour
killing it promoting this [ __ ]
like himself like he was his own
publicist right
so somebody was doing a show one night
and they asked me to come on i went up
there and there he is
and i go you know what bro this guy was
funny a couple years ago
let me watch this guy you want to see
what happens if he's really getting it
he had he had a couple jokes but he had
one joke dog
that used to kill me right it was about
[ __ ] killing animals or something it
used to [ __ ] kill me and it used to
it was one of those he's one of those
comedians that
tells you the joke
but he rides it right he rides the joke
out for six or seven minutes to the
point where normal people like when's
this guy gonna get the [ __ ] off the
stage right
i'm sitting there enjoying him for like
two minutes and all of a sudden he rips
into that joke
now it's 2008.
he was doing that joke in 97
right 98 he was doing that joke
i looked at him i was like that's why
comics killed himself bro because when i
walked out of the [ __ ] room
i'm like you're doing the same joke from
10 [ __ ] years ago
it's like think about lee you're in a
band
and every time you're on stage you're
playing the same song
it's the same thing
you know well they must like it or they
have to deal with it no it's laziness
bro it's lazy it's laziness it comes
down to the blood
i remember more with the bands but yeah
with comedians
i don't think people pay a comic to see
the same joke over and over again i know
after the second time i see the joke i'm
done i'm done that's why i hate doing
comedy on tv because how many tastes
they do and they all giggle like it's
funny stop you're embarrassing me you're
making me [ __ ] feel bad nothing's
just funny on the eighth take they're
still like
don't make me [ __ ] punch in the
[ __ ] hand
it's um
what are you reading you got notes
so you do got no look at me [ __ ] work
see what i'm saying you come prepared
and [ __ ] okay so here's
so for people who don't know i've been
doing
i've been trying every every tuesday
night i do like three or four minutes of
comedy oh you begin on stage a little
once a week but i i don't think i want
to do it as a profession but it's been
fun
um
but were you fearful at firstly i mean
you went from when we first started the
podcast he came in one morning
stuttering
his face was red
i got him high and he goes listen when
you do this podcast i don't want to be
on camera i don't want to talk right and
you know you can only talk so much by
yourself right
right and i would ask him [ __ ] creepy
questions and he would turn red and look
at me and his face like he was [ __ ]
like you know he was like you molested
him yeah he was working
he would work till five and then come to
my house at six so he'd be tired so i
would notice that when i go lee what do
you think of the yankees you know just
look at me like well and then all of a
sudden it just clicked
i made him go on stage or something we
did a live podcast and
you know the transition was easy i knew
it was going to be hard
i didn't do personal no i knew he was
the type of guy that if he thought about
it he would have a nervous breakdown so
i just got him sizzled i just got
no alcohol higher than [ __ ] he got like
a little nervous breakdown for about a
minute and then he snapped out of it
because the marijuana saved them right
and i did a live podcast with him and
from day one he took them
so there's people that you know they did
a survey years ago right right and the
biggest fear is not dying is fear of
speaking in public yeah
and i to a guy like me dog i sit there
and go are you [ __ ] crazy like to me
it came naturally like in the sixth
grade i would get up on stage every
friday and lip-sync my eyes adored you
by frankie valley
so i was used to it my mom had a bar and
she wouldn't make speeches and my mom
would ask me questions in front of
people so i didn't think nothing of it
when i heard that statistic i almost
died but then i have two friends
that they don't know that they've even
mentioned it to me when i come to the
shows and if you even look at me i will
leave the show yeah and then one time my
friend's dad came and i go mr dealer and
this [ __ ] shot out of there two
days later you can't do that to me
he goes i had to take my heart
medication in the car
yeah that was me i like before yeah so
when i see you go up i i don't even get
involved
do you have a set do you have a i have a
couple of things that i i wrote down but
oh i thought you had uh you recorded
yourself we were going to hear it i
don't wanna i don't wanna a little bit
you on stage bro
i don't watch him i listen to him you
know and i
i don't push him yeah i don't push him
but that's why you know what
when i was uh uh i helped some comics
when i was coming up and i i truly
believe that our friendships have been
severed because
when there were young comics i used to
push them but i was a dick bro i wasn't
with that nice guy you know i was raised
you know real hard ass so i coached
these guys like an [ __ ] you know we
would we would uh go you know i take him
on the road with me and then we'd get a
you know we'd go back to the hotel and
i'd say like the [ __ ] was that you
sucked man and and these guys would look
like i didn't know how badly it hurt
them i thought i was doing them good do
you know what i mean but they did get
better bro they got better but i don't
but i didn't know they're going to hate
me years later you know these guys uh
anyways man
another so that's good what you're doing
man no no no no i don't do anything no
no that you don't do it
that's good that's good that you're not
doing anything is what i'm saying it's
so weird how
people always want you
i don't know i don't know what i wanted
when i first got into comedy i was a
doorman
then i became the sound guy
is that the comment store no oh okay at
a club called whitsett it's not there no
i was there for like 25 years
it start i took the comedy class in
march and it opened like in april
and the guy that taught the comedy class
got me a job in there as a doorman and
then the sound guy quit so they made me
the sound guy and the door guy then they
made me the bar back and then i got on
stage
and the owner didn't like it
so he was like though you can't work and
do comedy
so i just started doing comedy but i was
fidgeting around with it right you know
like i didn't really i didn't know but
when i was there
my purpose to work at that club was to
ask comedians
they told me
but they didn't tell they told me what
to do and what things
but nobody ever tells you about the
experience yeah the experience of doing
this for me right now like
i could just write a book on 25 years of
company right and people go holy [ __ ]
like i'm ready to go like with a [ __ ]
microphone
because it's too much right it's too
much there's not enough paper
there's not enough paper yeah you know
the education like i got to tell you
something man
i came from cuba
there's people who like to do a lot of
things yeah one thing bro i went out of
the country twice i didn't [ __ ] like
it willy i don't like eating farming
chickens
the meat tastes different
the butter tastes different everything
tastes different to me
i'm captain comfort zone yeah i'm saying
so but one thing bro i like that it
showed me the country like i went to
every [ __ ] state to do comedy yeah
except maybe
i don't even [ __ ] know even utah yeah
who when i first got into county i
wasn't allowed in utah you know [ __ ]
like people like me would not be allowed
in utah and now that's one of my stops
every year well i'm sure
you know when you first went to utah it
was like was it was it where if you went
to a bar you had to sign an application
it was that is that because that's how i
was when i first started going to utah
like work when uh
i heard the law since change but but
like 20 15 18 years ago if you went to a
bar every bar demanded that they had
your application like if you're applying
for a job
i don't know if you
no yes i was yeah bro
from utah i went the first place i went
to utah was ogden utah it was close to a
military thing
i forgot who who was headlining dave
tribble sent me there that was my real
legit
road animal gig
like that was it i had been paid before
a cup of noodles but this was [ __ ]
eight hour drive yeah you know
60 bucks in my pocket and i got there
they go the the hotel is only has one
room i had to share the room with the
[ __ ] headliner all right that was my
first experience that guy he wasn't a
creepy guy he was okay
he was funny you say that man i i've had
the creepy guy did you ever work a club
called spellbinders in in houston no you
know who we know what happened to
spellbinders ralphie fell through the
stage there
no and he said
ralphie may yeah he found it he was 500
pounds and he went on the stage there
and he used to he used to be in the
strip mall years ago yeah no no yeah it
was one of the best clubs in houston i
did it years later when they had the
improv took it over okay
but ralphie fell to
the lady
you know till this day i bring it up to
him once once a month
if he calls me we'll be talking and i'll
go back that time he fell through the
stage he fell through it yeah oh he
didn't fall in front he didn't
fell through the stage there was a board
that was loose
his suit
oh brother you know you know he was
roommates years ago with joey medina
right
uh you know all please okay so i used to
go over over their house i'll tell you a
story bro okay so this is years i mean
i'm talking 18 maybe 20 years ago joey
and ralphie were roommates
we were all hungry at the time i could
barely pay my apartment right nobody
could okay so i get to their place and i
could smell pot roast man i got giant
pot roast this thing could feed six
people bro i'm not kidding you and i
looked at joey and i said you guys are
cooking right and then joey gave me a
look like no no no like stop like like
no like what do you mean and then he
took he goes that's that's ralphie's i
go
that's ralphie's like all of it he goes
yeah i go [ __ ] man it was all his bro so
so then i don't know how it happened
right me and joey go like this i'm going
to mcdonald's i don't know who said to
this day me and joey can't figure out
who said it first he goes hey wanna go
mcdonald's yeah let's go to mcdonald's
[ __ ] it mcdonald's let's go we go to
mcdonald's over in hollywood man uh
and we get to the counter i order my
food he orders his food and the lady
goes yeah that'll be 12.75
and then i look at joey like you're
gonna pay right and joey goes no i got
no money because you gonna pay i ain't
got no money i thought you were gonna
pay
and we had to walk out of there and
leave the food there bro
wait the pot roast [ __ ] no no but we
that was all ralph's let me tell you let
me tell you a creepy face am i right you
know this right okay this used to be off
this apartment was by paramount yeah
you made a right off of melrose
and it was like in this
in this [ __ ] uh it looked like
apartments that were built in the 40s
for [ __ ] like martians or something
so ralphie lived there alex raymundo
lived there yeah and somebody else lived
there
so one day i'm out doing a gig or
something like that i'm living in my car
it's got to be 98. okay and join medina
goes bro i'm going to do a uso tour
and uh alex is living in austin
and he goes the other guy lives in san
diego was ever staying there
he goes if you want just pay utilities
don't drink the alcohol or whatever
i stayed there for three months it was
the weirdest
three months why is that wrong of my
life
it was just
the weirdest three months of my life
place haunted or whatever at the time i
was haunted
and what was going on
yeah demons
following you
it was like
i had a girl on here in the podcast and
i was talking about the dirtiest
experiences of my life sexually okay
like drugs and people that i knew all
right
all those experiences pretty much like
three or four experiences happen in that
joey medina apartment
until he's a freak dirty and he wasn't
there
he left in like june and came back in
september
and i started staying there like in june
and the first two months i would watch
tv i'd cook i'd [ __ ] clean up after
myself i did laundry somewhere else
i slept in the back there was no air
conditioner it was fans but [ __ ] it i
was just happy to have a place to take a
shower and do comedy and [ __ ] like that
but i was doing blow i was at the comedy
store i didn't have no money i was just
doing blow i'd go out and get a package
20 bucks
but at that point that everything was
really moving fast comedy was moving
fast people were starting that's that's
the first time joy medina was one of the
first guys to do with independent cd
at that time in 98 with a [ __ ] yeah he
taped it yeah and
one night we were at ralphie may's house
and he put the cd and all three of us
fell asleep so that was a big joke for a
while a dog i'm tired put the jerry
medina seat down for a little
no disrespect to joey it was just
something that happened one day
joey was really good to me and opened up
his house to me
just off the top of my head i remember
three
experiences that were so disgusting
with women in that place and drugs
that were just like animalistic like i
still think about it today and go
what are those women thinking today like
i'm embarrassed
like it wasn't that wasn't supposed to
happen that one was supposed to come
over for smoker joint right one was
gonna come over to dublo and she was
married and one was a friend of joey's
that joey sent me an email going my
friend's coming up from san diego she's
gonna sleep in my room let us sleep i
get home there's no blankets on my
[ __ ] couch i go what the [ __ ] is this
i knocked on her door i go did you take
the blankets can i take one of the
blankets she goes i only have one
blanket she takes it off she's
completely naked i go what the [ __ ] does
this happen to me
how does this dirty [ __ ] happen to a
nice night what a [ __ ] night i never
get all coked up i got a couple rocks in
my pocket and this chicks naked on them
like that type of and i was poor
tuna fish
that type of [ __ ] like it was that type
of comedy experience i still remember
going to the store i was getting spots
at the store i had a car that had
no insurance and no registration
and the brakes were low like i was about
to kill somebody in that [ __ ] car but
i was relentless with it and it finally
got i didn't give a [ __ ] lead lee that
car went everywhere but you you know
funny you say that a joy
and leave
i'm telling you man there's a even
though you're broke as [ __ ] and you're
eating that tuna
out of the can with the mail
you feel like you're in control of life
because you're your own boss
do you know what i mean
like you don't have you but no but you
don't have to go clock in anywhere bro
you know joey
i'm sorry you know i would do it all
over yeah to get the same result
because me doing that tough life
and just not giving up
is why i'm still here today like it's so
weird those little moments that i still
remember yeah
other reasons the experiences that led
me to today
all right you know what i'm saying like
all that [ __ ] now i look back at all
that [ __ ]
10 years of [ __ ] people 10 years of
slipping on couches and
having a car with no insurance no
driver's license and no credit cards
because i was abandoned
for 10 years i just disappeared i didn't
do nothing taxes
no license i was the invisible [ __ ]
man dog
it's [ __ ] crazy to think about that
and then i met you guys and
that was weird because i would hang out
with you guys early then i would shoot
to the store
and then i would see you guys every
tuesday wednesday and thursday yeah and
it was crazy it was crazy yeah we
weren't allowed the big house
but those rooms made me the comic that i
am today
i always think about the brave bull bro
oh the bread boys i always you know i
see rudy now yeah and i always give rudy
hug because i say what the [ __ ] you want
to say bro i did 300 sets there 300
[ __ ] sets at that brave ball there
was a time where rooney paid what
remember it was 50 bucks for friday and
saturday but then in the summer you got
summer pay so it went down for 12.50 a
show with 15 a set right but you could
probably get like a burrito that was the
big thing in life get some food if you
could get food
that [ __ ] made up for everything yeah
that was a good gig that was a good gig
food and three drink tickets [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so i mean and then that's why that's one
of the big the deterrent is really is
how long it takes and sometimes like the
last few weeks since i've started doing
i was like [ __ ] i i was an idiot maybe i
should have started five years ago and
i'd be like comedy
but i i don't think it would have been
good because i would have been terrible
i would have been like i would have been
like i would have puked on stage it's
got to be your passion though man it's
not but yeah and then it's also true
it's got to be your passion
and i'm going to tell you something for
young comics today it's a different game
than when it was when you and i started
because
when you were listen
when i was doing carb in my fourth year
i was already making
was i was i make was i getting rich yeah
no i wasn't getting rich on the road but
i was covering my age
yeah i was just doing drugs and living
like a nomad but i couldn't i could i
couldn't have done bad there was
opportunity now now they don't even give
features hotel rooms
they don't get feature acts hotel rooms
they don't want to pay them either then
they don't get my hotel room these kids
live on that app
where they gotta get out of the room at
12. yeah and then they don't get a hotel
room until right before the show or
after the show because the hotel room is
92 percent off they get it for like 39
when you work with these kids at certain
comedy clubs yeah you're like holy [ __ ]
they got you living on a [ __ ] app to
see what hotel's going to give you a
room at 60 off at 10 o'clock at night
they don't even give you a [ __ ] hotel
room
to me i was homeless
yeah so those hotel rooms were a
sanctuary for me in those days all right
they're a [ __ ] sanctuary you got a
figure i was homeless
from 95
to 2000
homeless couches josh wolf's couch
ralphie mays floor joey medina's [ __ ]
thing my car
i was homeless guys
homeless in seattle i lived abroad
if i didn't live with her i had an
apartment with josh wolfe which was
basically a towel he got rid of that
apartment i moved into an office there
was no pictures of family smiling
so those were the five years i gave up
with [ __ ] nothing i mean there was
the hotel room
the office had a towel on the floor
but you know what man of all the comics
that i've of stories that i've heard of
comics coming up joey
i think nobody um
burned bridges as much as you and me man
no
because
listen
we're in l.a we're in hollywood we're in
a place where people master kissing ass
and you when i hear stories about you
and then and you know the [ __ ] that i
did
i think we were
some of those things that uh us taking
us a little longer to uh make some money
it was some of it we caused ourselves
man i remember doing a theater with you
bro i don't know if you remember this
that was the funniest we did a theater
in bakersfield all plays and uh and we
were
for whatever reason man we all got paid
and uh so we got our checks i had my
check in my pocket and then i hear you
screaming man and here's and i'm like
and it sounds like uh like you're gonna
fight like a fist fight and i'm going
holy [ __ ] joey's gonna fight somebody so
i i run up these stairs right because
and i go in this office and i see this
this little dude just scared and enjoys
joey's like hey you [ __ ] i told
you if you're gonna pay me you
[ __ ] you give me cash you son of
a [ __ ] i swear to god and this is what
cracked me up man i wanted to laugh but
i did it because it was serious and it
was but he goes because he had a brother
the guy had a brother and he goes if you
don't give me my goddamn mother i got
that money i'mma grab your ass and shove
you up your brother's ass
i wanted to die man willie gave me the
money though
willie gave me the money out of his
pocket and took the check we signed the
check over to willie
willie saw how mad i was because it was
valentine's day
and the guy called me at 5 30 and i
already had plans
me and my wife at the time my wife who
today that was my valentine and we had
already plans we were going to go to
sizzler
we're going to live without have sex and
[ __ ] and also i get this [ __ ] car to
[ __ ] go to a gig and i go listen i'll
come do the gig but at least give me
cash right get dinner up there i got
like a coupon
i'll never make it back
so when i got up there he thought i
wanted to make money for coke i had my
wife with me
my wife was right there my girlfriend
was right [ __ ] there i lived with her
i wasn't going away with that money in
those days she'd take it out of my
[ __ ] ass she knew i was a fiend
she knew the [ __ ] deal that's what
pissed me off and you know what
he signed me as a client
yeah he did that yeah then now we're not
together no more
but we're always on the phone yeah yeah
yeah we're always on the phone and we
talk and
you know he's a big-time manager yeah he
is she's a big guy
whatever i remember you scaring the [ __ ]
out of him that night bro
i uh respected a lot of your decisions
like i had heard things that you had
done
made me laugh my ass off but always uh
well i got i got thrown out of your home
club when i was open micro which one the
comedy comedy store you know for you
yelled at mitzi mitzi yeah i yelled at
her
you you know the story man she was
she was uh she auditioned all the
hispanic comics
in the uh the belly room
and every comic was up there [ __ ] you
know shaking and baking for her you know
what i mean and then i remember uh
johnny sanchez was sitting next to her
like buttering up to remember all the
comics would butter up to her and i
remember going out there and
but we did the jokes we did our material
without an audience
and i started thinking man you you know
that's [ __ ] up mitzi in my head i'm
thinking you have the white comics in
front of an audience you have the black
comics in front of an audience but you
have us with just telling jokes to you i
i just felt like you know uh uh the
subhuman man and in the middle of a bit
i just said hey [ __ ]
i go what the [ __ ] and she's what did
you say i said what the [ __ ] you're
gonna you're gonna audition us like this
like with some [ __ ] animals and i
grabbed the mic you know the story they
were all there it was like 12
uh latino comics and i just threw the
mic on the floor and i left and she said
what's this i remember as i'm going down
those stairs in the belly room i can
hear hear screaming
um what's his name what's his name and i
ran back up and i go my name's willy
barcena [ __ ] don't you ever [ __ ]
forget it and you know what joey she
never forgot it man because
10 years later danny devito was doing a
fundraiser and he saw me somewhere and
he did his fundraiser at the comedy
store and he showed her all the comics
he wanted and she said yeah everybody
except this guy
so she had a good memory bro
that's crazy yeah why you know the stuff
i did man
yeah
but it's crazy because the comedy
community
always reacted to your actions and my
actions
like they were way off [ __ ] line but
before the show you and i were talking
about the people we were raised with
yeah and how we were raised with and how
we held somebody's word wow yeah so this
place rattles when you come from that
type of backing to california to l.a if
you're thinking of becoming an actor or
a comedian and you move out here and
let's say you're from a tight-knit
pittsburgh neighborhood that's primarily
catholic your mom hit in the head with a
frying pan your dad's blue collar
whatever the [ __ ] you came from you come
from a different world than this yeah
and when you come out here after a year
or two even when you get success
you're really looking at it going this
ain't right that's what test people
that's the willpower yeah that some
people look around and go this ain't
[ __ ] normal
to me it took the longest yard to go
this ain't normal all right this is not
normal it's not it's not reality this is
not reality well we grew up and we were
talking before the show started anything
and i think what the the part of our
personalities joy is we know
okay some of the guys that we know
growing up as kids that got murdered
yeah there was uh
you know it was a i don't know over here
there was drive-bys bro it was crazy
gang stuff but there was a lot of guys
too that that growing up
people that i know that got killed
for lying for just lying or or stealing
from a certain group of people
they would hey that guy's dead and then
you find out you know why
so
you knew growing up look if i keep my
nose clean i i know these guys are bad
people but all i have to do is not lie
and i'll survive right yeah once in a
while you have you had to fight
right but if you kept your nose clean
for the most part
that was a sure way to stay alive and my
and that means you don't get into other
people's business
you don't lie
and uh hey i didn't see i didn't see
nothing i don't know nothing i don't
give a [ __ ]
right
i don't know nothing i don't know
nothing yeah totally all the time and
then we come to we can come no nothing
you confuse people yeah i don't know
what do you mean you would i don't know
none but then when they're we're in this
comedy world with these actors slash
comedians and everything and they're the
biggest backstabbing lying weasels in
the world and you're like dude
in the real world you get slapped in the
mouth for that and that's how stuff me
and you
couldn't tolerate yeah i mean not that
weird i mean i'm not the last thing from
a tough guy man i'm a big [ __ ] but you
know
you know even a [ __ ] [ __ ] smacks
back right who are you saying touching
no but i learned a
hard lesson when i was younger that
we
it's never really good to stand up for
something like like and that's [ __ ] up
in a way to say i don't really know how
to say it but
for whatever reason i was at a camp we
were my whole bunk was mad at the
council for something so we signed a
petition on the wall and i walked up to
the thing and i said
we wanted this guy fired or something
and they like they sat me down there
like
yeah like they like everyone riled me up
but like and they're like oh yeah we're
with you we're with you but then when
they come back then not yeah not
everyone's with you
so it's like you can't you can never
really trust look everyone's always
going to be with you then but when i cut
when it gets down to it no one's really
going to be there somewhere can't
believe yeah next time i can't i'm
really white no no no where did you go
how old were you around this time i'm
curious man there's actually a listener
who was a counselor um
how old were you around this time fifth
grade
okay so you were 10 or 11 you had a
little dignity to you yeah you learn the
lesson though yeah you have a valuable
lesson
it's really weird but really no
you know
uh
i was telling i was telling
i i know willie and i respected willie
15 years ago because i knew willie was
doing something
i knew willie would see you and he'd see
something in you he'd invite you to his
rooms and his rooms used to be packed in
those days
and they were mexicans and they were
drinking and they're ready to laugh and
was always a two token white guy a token
black guy but there was always hot
chicks and i remember going to the one
on two wednesday was a coyote yeah but
tuesdays was the one by the car
dealership
and i remember the first time
gave me 40 bucks and somebody put coke
in my hand in the tent
on the way out you had to walk through a
tent
so the show was inside but once you
walked out that side door
there was a 20-foot tent where you could
smoke and [ __ ] in there somebody put a
coke rock in my hand like i'm gonna come
here
but i
you were helping a lot of comics i
remember you coming up to me a couple
times and saying say this that joke's
funny and i knew where you were coming
from and i respected you because you won
the [ __ ] tonight show
you're in the [ __ ] tonight show bro
okay that's it that the proof is in the
pudding you got the right to say
something it's that dude who don't get
spots
that comes up to you and goes dog you
know be funny no no none of your [ __ ]
jokes you don't even know what the
[ __ ] tigers you're in the back
watching me and [ __ ] you're still
signing up to [ __ ] get spots and [ __ ]
like this those are the guys that piss
me off when you'd come up to me in those
days and go put that there and put that
there i
i'd go right back to the store and do
exactly what the [ __ ] you told me
because i saw those tonight shows
and i go will he's a lot of things
but when he could write a [ __ ] joke
jack from [ __ ] scratch and it wasn't
until a couple years ago because i
hadn't seen you no more
i hadn't seen you you were doing this
you were doing that and one night i get
home and pool i put some showtime
special on willie my center and i was
floored
i was floored like i remember days later
seeing a bunch of young comics and going
dawg
the show that made me do comedy was uh
uh when i saw dyson special that's what
really pushed me i like the
beyond the sunset strip
but there was uh uh uh
i saw nick apollo
one night nick nick yeah
on the young comedian special live from
tempe arizona nick's one of the good
guys by the way everybody bombed
everybody bombed on that show ray romano
bomb janine garofalo bomb david spade
bomb and all of a sudden this [ __ ]
monster
from new york went up there that didn't
give a [ __ ]
and he said is this place hot or is it
me or is this place 200 yards from the
[ __ ] sun the air conditioner in your
room and walt disney woke up
in my room he was frozen
he just went he destroyed the [ __ ]
room i don't know where i'm going with
the story oh he was a good writer at the
time yeah you could tell that he would
spend time you could tell he could even
his jokes were raunchy or whatever but
you could tell they were well written
jokes right and when i used to watch him
and you i used to go these guys are
doing something
that not everybody else is doing in that
group of joke type people right you know
which seinfeld has a little bit of that
a little something to cheer up the room
where's the broom what's the name of it
febreze
okay joey
but uh
no there was no i like what no i gotta
tell you lee so i get a call i'm on the
road and i get a call from this like
three years ago when the showtime
special came out
and my message from joey is hey
[ __ ] i just saw your showtime
special it's [ __ ] hilarious i swear
to god if you were white you'd be rich
it was just brilliantly it was just
written well
you could tell he had the notes he
planned it out
you could tell he knew exactly where to
look at the camera he had all his marks
down and i sat there i go this is a true
[ __ ] professional man
and it's really weird that when we
started the podcast tonight
we we categorized comedy and we were
talking about latins
and i got a i got a problem
i love everybody
and when i see comics doing this [ __ ] i
really like it but every once in a while
you get a person dressed up as somebody
and in l.a this is actorville
and before i got here there was a guy
that was running game and he was very
successful he was selling his soul and
the people around him were selling
himself he claimed to be a mexican guy
but there was no he had 10 mexican blood
in him the blood he had in them was a
[ __ ] pirate you know he had the blood
of a pirate you know and
dog he got on my last nerve like every
move he made i irritated me and that was
jeff valdez yeah you know and i remember
going up there that night i had lost my
cool like yeah it was at this that's
that store right that was marilyn's
thing yeah you know i couldn't have him
in the room yeah like that's the type of
person i am like i knew what he put
marilyn through because marilyn used to
call me crying and say
jeff made me showcase again he's on you
know he but then i know he gave her a
show and all that stuff and he was only
paying the fifty thousand that was i
don't know what the [ __ ] happened right
me in my mind i didn't want him there he
lost it i was there bro i was gonna i
felt before i go man
oh i went off first off i hadn't done
coke in seven or eight days
so right there dawg i was dying inside
really i was dying to bump into a guy
like him you know what i hadn't done
coke at that time it was like four or
five days it was killing me
it was [ __ ] killing me and now
marilyn dies
yeah like marilyn [ __ ] dies and what
happened was i went to new york
and i had a great hotel room my buddy
said i got these free miles bro take my
this hotel room it was in sea caucus
right and for the first time i'm not in
the single i'm in like this [ __ ]
suite right with booze in the
refrigerator and for some reason i go
you know what bro i don't want no
cocaine time
i did a benefit for the cops on friday
that did a benefit for the high school
basketball team on saturday
saturday again
i went to the [ __ ] show on the way
home somebody said you want to take a
ride i go
and that night marilyn died
and i came back the next day and then
the everything was on wednesday and when
i went to the [ __ ] thing there was a
war going on because
paul said he was going to pay for the
funeral but he didn't want montoya there
i mean it's a [ __ ] funeral right and
next thing you know i'm sitting there
it's wednesday and i see [ __ ] jeff al
desert 12 o'clock walking into the
church
that already started [ __ ] me i waved
at everything but i'm like what is this
[ __ ] hypocrisy right right you know
and then i went home and people called
me up and they said you got to go down
there and i'm like i'm not going down
there
i was hurting so much we were talking
about the store yeah i didn't want to go
either man i don't know
who talked me into going with my wife uh
who talked me into going jody ferdinand
i was i was in my underwears at home and
i told my wife i'm not going i'm not
going and she goes you know what you
should be respectful it shouldn't be
about you and that's why i went because
i hate going to those i hate those
things you know i did not want to be
involved i wanted to go to bed at 8
o'clock anything after 8 o'clock in
those days i was in pain i'm not doing
coke on all those days i'd do as much as
i could and i'd smoke pot smoke pot
smoked pot until i just passed out at 9
30 from the [ __ ] pain
and i remember going you know what [ __ ]
it i'll go down to maryland's and on the
way back i'll get a package right and
dog when i walked in there and they said
you go up there first i didn't see jeff
no no i did see jeff i saw jeff getting
food
he was getting free food him and his
wife and the attorney and i go look at
this [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
and right there he signed his own death
warrant and right there i went to the
side of the stage doug and i was fuming
and the spanish chick came up to me and
she goes you got to open up the show
or you got to go up first or something
like that like okay i'll go up first
and i went up there and i'm up there dog
and i'm trying to do material but i
could see him from the corner of my eye
and my blood pressure was boiling i
hadn't done coke in a few days
and it went from they went from no
material to
[ __ ] torture
[ __ ] you [ __ ] your wife you're a [ __ ] oh
you're a [ __ ] jew mexican [ __ ]
oh my god i go you're too greasy to be a
[ __ ]
mexican too much of a [ __ ] slime to
be a jew you [ __ ]
and he's like my name's on the wall
you sucked as a comic oh that's right
with your [ __ ] jew hat on with the
dingles he used to put a yarmulke on
with little dinglebells like a mexican
wood whatever the [ __ ]
it used to drive me crazy dog when i saw
those pictures and he bought a club with
judy brown he was just wrong like i just
thought he was wrong and i thought i
thought in the back of my mind like
somebody mexican should have gone off on
him
but nobody did and i was pissed i was
like this guy then he did a second
festival where he rented out the theater
on vine
and the other one do you remember he had
george lopez and rudy and everybody
signed up for it and then a week before
everybody pulled out
and he kept calling me i'm going come on
i'll send the car for you and i'm like
bro you're making 55 a ticket you're not
paying nobody all right and that's when
i really got pissed off at him and i
just didn't like it no more i'm like i
don't need these [ __ ] people my life
no
that was indicative of a lot of the
people that were that right now that are
in l.a bro that's why
you know uh i was pissed off after time
man with these i was telling you when we
before we even got in there i said man i
i hated all these meetings you go to and
these cats give you hugs and they tell
you how much they love you and then you
go home then your age my agent calls me
and tells me yeah that guy [ __ ] hated
you what do you mean he hated me [ __ ]
guy gave me a hug
i thought we're best friends and there's
so much [ __ ]
in this business and that that guy was
was a you know an example of the
[ __ ] that we uh
you know well that's the thing that
we couldn't deal with at first you and i
we didn't know how to navigate ourselves
you made up you said late early on that
you went to a a festival one time and
you weren't socially you you felt like
you weren't socially yeah until this day
i don't feel socially
accepted at those functions yeah no i
feel like the odd man out man i don't go
to him i don't want to go to festivals i
don't want to do none of that stuff i
don't want to i don't want to have to be
at a bar
with people talking at no time i don't
like that no more
i can't lie to you i can't listen to
this specific you're like
don't listen to me i grew up in a ball
okay let me just ask you a question most
people don't go into a bar today at 14.
i grew up in a generation
where if you if you were a dad and you
brought your kids to the bar they could
sit them at the bar they could drink
soda and watch the game i did that with
my dad all the time yeah you can't do
that today you can't even think of doing
that really yeah at 8 o'clock we serve
alcohol there's nobody under 18 we'll
lose our license everybody's walking
around [ __ ] scared
that sucks that was the best i used to
get shirley temples yeah that's what you
do you eat a thousand [ __ ] cherries
until your mind goes crazy and you get a
[ __ ] headache
what was i talking about
no no we're talking about valdez man
you know and how
you know the sliminess of well that's
chinese bro that for five or six years i
didn't get work because of that
yeah in fact a couple of years ago i was
involved in the project
and also they stopped calling me and i
asked a friend of mine they said did you
go off on a producer a couple of years
ago
at the comedy store he didn't even know
the story and i go yeah one he goes
uh they don't want you involved in the
project oh man it's
i didn't hey listen i i spoke up for
what i believed
he disappeared right he's gone that's it
he's around he's got a facebook page
yeah
you know what man i'm actually i'm
pretty sure i'm going to uh at least
suspend my facebook page why would
happen
you said something to me last night you
said that like whatever you're doing
whatever you're looking at i want to
take it away and i think what it is i
think it's facebook
i think it's too much
because there's just there's so much
listen man
we had this conversation last week
i was at a bar last night trying to do
comedy okay i got a cheese tray in front
of me and i got waffles with [ __ ] and
it's for everybody right rodrigo was
there but chrysler was there joe perez
was there lee was there people coming
over and saying hello
then there was a break in the ball
willie
and there was three more there was two
latin chicks two chubby little mexican
girls with a black dude and they were
all giggling and then next to them there
was another guy and then two more guys
down the corner
out of all those people
there was two people who weren't looking
at their [ __ ] phone
and it was me and joe perez and for the
first time last night
george perez no this kid named joe
he's a young kid 20 years old that's a
comedy funny kid i'm sitting at this bar
and i'm watching this baseball game yeah
and all of a sudden i look over and i
see all these people the guy next to me
is texting his [ __ ] text is going on
this guy's texting the three chicks are
looking at one phone
giggling like yeah then they're playing
like [ __ ] pokemon at the bar
you know and i looked at them and i go
when i was a kid i would be at a bar
drinking i'd be drinking i'd be having a
good time i'd be eating the
there was 12 people at the bar
and seven of them were on their phones
like it was the end of the world and it
dawned on me i'm like i said something
to lee and bernie get off the [ __ ]
phone you guys gotta stop you guys gotta
stop
it's gotta end somewhere i wish i could
wake up one day and just delete
everything
but it doesn't take that much of my time
i get up i do it in the morning and i
move on with my day sometimes i wanna
smoke a joint on periscope that takes
three [ __ ] minutes to be very honest
i get lost in it and it takes up
probably hours of my day yeah i know
you're home [ __ ] thinking thinking
because you cause here's what happens
they have these videos
so you scroll with plays haha that was a
funny video and then it just scrolls up
and there's like eight thousand and you
have to keep doing this no i don't
that's when i call you at eight and
you're telling me you're sending emails
i know you're [ __ ] around
looking at stupid videos of chinese
you're out there [ __ ] around no no no
no no no no no see that's why i'm
thinking about deleting it don't delete
it just take it off your [ __ ] phone
start taking [ __ ] off your phone that
delete you from your [ __ ] life
start taking [ __ ] off your phone that is
taking you away from life next time
you're caught up in your phone look up
and go i could have just got shot in the
[ __ ] head
next time you're in that little pond
with the bird where you go smoke a
cigarette or drink your [ __ ] coffee
and you look out and you look at your
[ __ ] phone look up one second
and look think to yourself right now i
could be getting shot in the head a
terrorist could just take me and if i
was looking up i could have caught this
[ __ ] hidden under a tree and
played [ __ ] possum
you understand me lee you know i want to
die man do you want to die
no that conversation we had last week
about hari
really sunk with me where he threw away
his iphone and he went back to the
little phone and he said he was taking
too much of his time
i don't you know this i don't use the
[ __ ] on this i don't need this they just
i've been with sprint for 20 [ __ ]
years
yeah no and
i would be lost without gps so i need it
right now because you i don't know
how do you think people got around with
the [ __ ] horse and buggy you think
they had gps yeah but when i first got
here they used to give you a paper thing
and you had to go to where you wanted to
go and it was page 819 and you had to
get a magnifying glass thomas
you one time that the agostino cost me
an hour of
i wanted to talk to you guys about
something that that that's real
important to me
and one of the reasons why willie's here
wow
i got the special
i'm shooting for new wave october 15th
i did the math i was thinking about it
one day
and
two people have given me jokes i mean
100 people have given me jokes two times
i used a joke one time willie gave me a
joke like in
99 he goes you should tag it like that
at one of those theater latin things up
in [ __ ] uh texas no up the corner
here we used to do
not madam yeah modesto and all those
years ago there was a lot of action up
there and there was a black dude that
was a football coach a high school
football coach and he used to do rooms
up there every six weeks and he didn't
pay us bad and we'd get a hotel room and
smoke pot and giggle but one night you
told me one joke about a boat or
something from cuba that i should try it
and i tried it and the other time a girl
gave me a joke and i did it and a year
later some guy accused me of stealing
his joke and i went to her and i go did
you write the joke and she goes no i
heard everyone i go why would you give
me a [ __ ] stolen joke so after that i
don't listen to [ __ ] nobody i just
mind my [ __ ] business because you end
up doing somebody else's [ __ ] joke
and you whatever
but i thought about something i go you
know what
i've heard of people having a special
and hiring six writers to do this
special and they do that dirty work i
didn't want that i wanted to do the
dirty work i wanted to be a part of the
dirty work and be a part of the process
and go out there this is gonna force me
to be a better comic
and i said to myself who can i [ __ ]
work with as a coach
like if i wanted to [ __ ] coach in
stand-up
to talk to me about stand-up i would
trust myself with maybe two people
and there isn't two people there was one
person that was you
uh bro when you uh i gotta tell you man
that was very special when you when you
came up to me and said uh hey brother
will you work with me on on my special
because i've always been a big fan of
yours bro so when you told me that i was
like hell yeah man i thought about it i
broke it down in my head and i go listen
man he's the only guy i'm gonna listen
to
why because the tonight shows
because
that
is the best formation
of a set a human being could do in my
world i admire that for people who talk
[ __ ] on the tonight show they can suck
my dick because you want me to tell you
something
i could kill the tonight show
because it's my world it's four minutes
and 58 seconds but i'm fiercely
terrified of it
you understand me so when i see somebody
kick ass on it i understand the level of
how good they are and the level of
professionalism that it takes like you
said before it's a corporate gig
to me it's too big my circuitry would go
off i would start talking to the
audience and ask people what they do for
a living
what do you do for a living
like i would [ __ ] not handle it
so when i wanted to put you know i want
to still put my life into it and my
words i wanted you to come and
instruction that [ __ ] and that's exactly
like every time i leave you i talk to
you for an hour the reason why i only
talk to you for an hour is not because i
don't like you
it's because i got to process what you
just told me you just blew my [ __ ]
mind
you know you just blew my [ __ ] mind i
never even thought of comedy writing
the way you think of comedy writing i
have a complete different admiration for
comedy writing now now
because of my connection with you i'm
never going to throw away material again
once that special is shot
i take a week off and we get back to the
tape recorders league and we go to every
dirty bar and [ __ ] machina
and we get an hour and six months that's
the only way i'm gonna do it that's the
way you do it and then the next six
months you chop that [ __ ] up add
the seasoning yeah that [ __ ] and
that's how you do it that's how a
[ __ ] professional comedian does it
and i did not do it like that forever
so now i'm re-energized now i know how
to do this now i know you taught me the
steps how to get in there and we're
gonna every time i shoot a special it's
me and you through the wheels fallout
because i listened to you i wouldn't
listen to somebody else bro
i would have never listened to somebody
else listen bro i'm gonna tell you i i
gotta i i said you know you you when we
we were talking uh i think yesterday or
a couple days ago and you said how
how much uh because you're around ufc
and joe rogan and you're around all
these guys that fight and you're into
jiu-jitsu
and you said to me man willie uh i i
realize now
how martial arts evolves how how guys go
from learning something to evolving and
getting even better and you said you
applied it to your life right yeah to to
your standup yes okay now here's where i
i i i applied the same thing
you know reuben castillo i don't know if
you ever heard of the guy he's a funny
[ __ ] guy man this guy
three losses right he lost two salvador
sanchez
alexis arguelle and julio
all right this guy is funny as [ __ ]
where he goes hey willy i'm gonna tell
you something if it wasn't for those
three [ __ ] guys i would have been the
greatest fighter of all time
but but anyways this reuben castillo man
is
this guy used to do a show a boxing show
here in l.a years ago with chick hearns
they used to do a show on on a local
television
i i really pick his brain when it comes
to boxing and
and that circle of people he's around
anyways when when when uh when i
realized how they coach like really good
boxers
is
they don't change the style what they'll
say is let me see you box and and you
could box
awkwardly but they'll they'll teach you
to fight from that they don't change you
they don't change
okay you're going to be an awkward
looking fighter but you're going to be a
good awkward looking fighter or you're
going to be a southpaw but you're going
to be a good southpaw you know what i
mean
when when i when when when when i hear
you on stage first first of all i crack
the [ __ ] up all the time to me it's just
it's it's
easy it's an easy gig man because uh all
i all i see is is is just telling you
going hey man instead of doing joke a
joke like uh
one two three why don't we why don't we
start with three and and then put two
here and one here and has it has a
smoother transition that's all i do man
that's all i do
to your creativity you know and the fact
honestly brother i'mma testing there's
not a lot of comics i respect i mean you
and i have been you've seen me at comedy
clubs where i walk in and i probably say
hi to two people of the there will be 20
comedians in the room and there's only
one that i go up and shake hands with
and say how are you good to see you
how's the family everything i do my set
and i leave i i i i don't like a lot of
people joining me you know that really
and and
and listen man uh
the fact that that uh that i'm i'm uh uh
you trust me with this
hey bro it's a privilege man as the
privileged brother amen
you know i'd like your fans to check out
my uh my netflix special bro now how
long has it been on this uh six weeks
and what's the name of the special
called the truth hurts okay you watch
this [ __ ] special guys
and you send me a [ __ ] tweet or you
send willy a tweet go watch your [ __ ]
favorite comedians
and then watch this this special
watch how he prepares his material watch
his conviction
watch how every watch it not once but
twice three times if you want to really
learn
watch where he puts and positions his
words
that's
something that you can't even go to
college for
you really can't that's something that
comes from
and i always watched you do it and we
sat together and you're like i think you
should say that word
and i would go home and go jesus [ __ ]
christ and then i would go on stage and
it would [ __ ] just work like a charm
and that's the first time willie i
wouldn't take instruction from a lot of
people hey bro
no i've been seeing you a lot more
recently i haven't been i haven't been
calling your shows as much but now i
have and you haven't been repeating it
so
what are you doing are you just trying
new stuff every time here and then what
i'm doing is
you tape it willie tapes it if willie
tapes it he takes it home and he gives
me notes if you send it to me the next
day i sit with a blank notebook
with a blank notebook i put the date on
top
and i listen to the whole recording with
earphones on
and then i
really don't do much i i can't lie to
you lately i've been
laughing i cannot lie to you later some
of the [ __ ] you tell me the next day
i forget about now i'm hearing it
now i'm hearing it i'm going wow so now
i understand that tuesday nights for me
is 30 minutes of material and i'm gonna
get
eight
and it's not really material it's just
a couple sentences maybe a word maybe
hummus dick
maybe something we said you know you
threw me an idea the other day and i
wrote it down right and i'll wait till
the improv to give you all that right so
you can watch it we'll do our thing next
friday night on the ice house we're at
the ice house this is next friday night
the second september 2nd
yeah we're doing two shows on friday
night so i'll get to do whatever
material you want but whatever whatever
time you want me to do i'll just take
two sets that night and do the first
show two two uh two uh
half of it yeah the other half like that
and i don't care what the audience
thinks just so you can hear it and
they'll give me a cd
then i'll work on it again during the
week up there and then friday and
saturday you and i together again at the
improv on melrose
on september 9th and 10th
so we'll tape it again then we'll look
at that the following week i go to
austin i come back with five more sets
then i go to new york and i come back
with four more sets then we got a week
off
that week i see you like two or three
times i go to columbus
i come back from columbus and i got
tuesday at the comedy store we'll run it
again
and then the week before when i come
back from columbus tuesday night before
chicago i run it again in the belly room
i go to chicago i tape the special had a
baby man that's the process i'm using
that's the training music this is this a
man without a plan is not a man
i'm not gonna get another shot at this
okay i barely got this one i got one
special in 25 [ __ ] years if you think
listen you and i discussed something and
i discussed it the other day on the
[ __ ] show on sunday and i give props
when props is due you and i watch the
fight i've been telling you the main
thing i got about mma was
every time a fighter showed up and says
he's got a strong punch
and after every fighter that's all he
had to tell me he didn't evolve
he didn't go to jiu jitsu class he
didn't even try to wrestle gsp used to
go to gymnasts and he'd go to mambo
class yeah and then he'd go to pilates
with broads then he go swim you know
that's why gsp became who gsp was
i could
talk you know me i could smoke 15 joints
do a bit about sucking [ __ ]
do 15 minutes about getting my dick
sucked in the shower i'll do a bit about
something generic and then i'll close
with something disgusting
and you watch it and you go yeah he was
funny but after 20 minutes he lost me
because it was the same joe diaz
he didn't evolve
he didn't evolve i don't want that in my
special
i want it i want people to see him go
wow joey actually put working like conor
mcgregor he's disciplined yeah he he
still said [ __ ] 80 times the last time i
saw it he said 198.
he didn't say [ __ ] he didn't do you
know listen when i'm on stage and people
are laughing i'm doing a sex joke you
think i feel good look at me i'm not 20
no more
i'm a 53 year old dude doing a joke
about eating [ __ ] that's funny we
giggle
but it's not what i
it's not what i want the country to see
whether it goes on netflix or or [ __ ]
show time wherever it goes i'm going to
have one shot at this
so this is why i i wanted to show up
like [ __ ] conor mcgregor the most
important is unprepared yeah that's it
you prepared your special comes true you
do your hour 15 you're out with 10. they
chopping into 55 they show a tape are
you jerking off with a tuxedo on with
your buddies in the beginning and you
got yourself a special let me give some
shout outs and i'll get you out of here
let me give a shout out to my man
chair seven raj don wrangler cleo
jake music
richie montgomery mcanis i don't know
what the [ __ ] you and irish dude i love
you
chad rizza
uh greg and lin up there in seattle
holding it down for uncle joey and
matthew alaveras
don't forget i'm at the ice house
wednesday night in the back so i'll do
another hour back there nice and send
that to you august 31st and then i'll be
back there the ice house has become
[ __ ] workout headquarters
all right that's it man
really i'm happy you came on what's the
name of your special again no
expectations no it's called the truth
hurts what the [ __ ]
it's called the truth hurts
it's uh and it's uh right now it hurts
the truth hurts if you want to see how
that medium works because see here's
what the problem is right now
and it really burns me up
because now it broadened my horizon a
lot of things
it broadened my horizon on music it
broadened my horizon on
we were talking about the aba and the
man right and we were talking about the
differences of how
the aba was for players who went to
college but they had to go to a
community college they [ __ ] got three
chicks pregnant in the eighth grade
their family was on welfare he didn't
take the acts he shot a teacher in high
school but they end up in the aba and
they led the league in scoring or
tremendous basketball players the ab the
nba was more civilized right
the same thing happens in comedy
but you people don't see it
okay you have this
you have these great run of comedians
that are media fueled comics
okay you have a great run of them and
some of them deserve the publicity and
one of them couldn't [ __ ] make you
laugh if they had a gun to their [ __ ]
head
but that's just the way life goes
the media stands behind them and fuels
them you guys embrace them and there's
nothing you can do then you have this
other level style of comic
and let's say as a comic like myself a
comic who's been around for a while and
one day he pulls a stunt but he does
something and he [ __ ] people start
coming to his shows and he starts
getting better as a comic but eventually
he moves on like everything else
everywhere you know even everybody moved
from led zeppelin there's nothing you
could do
it's evolution
but
those comics that
uh
do that that have been around and then
their popularity goes away because the
show goes away or the tonight show goes
away or the whatever the tv show goes
away these guys keep working the public
just dismisses them you know but these
guys are still there's some guys that
take their six million dollars and they
go [ __ ] stand up comedy that's what punk
has [ __ ]
but this comic style like i was a comic
down and i'm a comic now that's what i'm
doing and they keep improving but
meanwhile you're going to see the comics
that the media is pushing on you yeah
this guy's in your hometown you're like
i've never really heard of him they said
he was on a tv show in the 90s on abc i
really don't want to see him you know
what i'm saying yeah we're into there's
a lot of great comedians that are
working today that nobody goes to watch
because everything else is fueled at
this style of comedy or they have to
have a tattoo or a beard or glasses
right yeah i was in the hotel i was
watching comedy i saw 10 comics i've
never seen them before but they were all
dressed
weird like they all had something
like beards like three of them had
beards you know what i'm saying like
that they're going to cut a [ __ ] tree
it's a manufactured persona right it's a
manufactured persona yeah they i saw the
girls with tattoos and half a head was
shaved and then another guy came up and
he was playing the [ __ ] nerd and
another guy came up and he was belushi
jr you know he was trying to jump up
like the [ __ ] dude who died from
drugs right so it's just really weird
you uh
are one of those guys that
are [ __ ] a great comedian thank you
brother and someday somebody's gonna
notice that hang a picture of you will
put a statue of you up you know you look
at you know i heard a story a couple
weeks ago that
ralphie may was at the improv one night
[ __ ] up on [ __ ] whatever okay and
he looked over there was a picture of
seth rogen up there he took it off the
wall and ripped it up and broke it in
half or something like that
he told the improv so then a couple
weeks ago he went to montreal
and he had to do something seth rogan
was the judge
and seth rogen heard about what ralphie
did and i don't know what the [ __ ] the
story is you know
in our world we know who the you know
it's like when somebody says to me well
that tv show is great he's great on that
show then he's a comedic actor he's not
a stand-up comic
that's different you just said in your
in the beginning you were there with d.l
hewgley this is
chris suckers suckers are the guys who's
talking right yeah these guys are still
around
they're still [ __ ] comedians these
guys didn't give up once the tv show
went down i know i wasn't he back on the
road chris chris tucker got back yeah
yeah he started traveling again started
gigging again what's up dog it's weird
how
fake the awards are too because there's
one of those guys who
uh a convenient no one really has
respect for
but has a show yeah all i've heard is
everyone hates it
and i was driving down the street today
this is the billboard for emmy
nominations
i'm like i haven't heard one
good review of this show how does that
have been for emmy nominations you know
you just you know it's funny because
joe you touched on something man that
i've always talked about on stage with
with the little bit of audience i could
you know when i get my audience to come
see i got i got a small audience but
those [ __ ] are loyal bro
eastside
no bro but i always said like this man
like like these you know like you said
comics that that for whatever
i don't know whatever happens man the
the industry kisses their ass loves them
these guys these guys know how to play
the game
and what to me what they become is like
like i ask them think of a hamburger
right now right away they say mcdonald's
what's the bur what's the worst burger
you can have there's a big mac you know
what i mean it's just but if you really
think of a good burger i know a place
called um rick's burgers and it's it's
on fletcher and riverside it's just this
one place well they might have two i
think there's one in alhambra they got
saved some money and bought another
another but i'm like a rick's burger bro
i just don't have that mcdonald's money
but [ __ ] my burger's delicious brother
you know what i'm saying
but listen i hope your your your people
check out check out the special and and
hit me up let me let me know what you
guys think if you think it suck dick
tell me hey you know what suck dick but
if you if you liked it hit me up listen
one thing about these people know is i
don't like them
i wouldn't have you in that chair if i
didn't have the utmost respect for you
so
they know they know they're sick and
tired of buying [ __ ] [ __ ] and
seeing [ __ ] they want to watch good
[ __ ] if you want to watch a real comic
you watch this [ __ ] special and take
notes
and you might whatever say well listen
watch what he's [ __ ] doing you could
watch the work in it
you ever go to a [ __ ] place and you
look at a statue
and it's a guy that just [ __ ] put a
mold on it but then you go to another
place and you see a statue you go wow i
can see the work and the detail that i
put into that and the the restaurant
holder and come over here can i ask you
a question about that statue where'd you
get it from me because i took the guy 16
[ __ ] years
that's what it feels like when you see
willie barcena performing you're not
going to see you're going to see a
well-structured [ __ ] show
sometimes it goes off the rails you know
what i'm saying sometimes there's a
couple cocktails
involved this [ __ ] happens hey
that's right but every [ __ ] uh ain't
nothing wrong with that let me give a
shout out to my main [ __ ]
datsusara
baddest [ __ ] out there i really
like listen i got about 30 more pounds
and i could fit into the [ __ ] key
they sent me and i can't wait i'm going
to do flying sidekicks in the [ __ ]
the whole thing i'm in love with their
bags i'm in love with the fanny pack you
know i don't travel without the fanny
pack up the wallet the [ __ ] ipod the
[ __ ] rolling papers the lighters they
got rash guards they got fanny packs
they got big bags they got little bags
listen everything about them i'm
impressed with
the durability of their [ __ ] bag that
they sent me like i said i got 19
pockets they sent me a [ __ ] canteen
the same one robert duvall gave the
soldier and the apocalypse now he can
any guy who's holding his guts could
drink out of my campaign and [ __ ]
but no all [ __ ] around do me a favor
go to dsgear.com take a look at the
great selection of rash guards geez
i think they only have two geese but let
me tell you something the hemp quality
they got belts they got bags i mean if
they if you want it they got high
quality stuff and it's
well priced and i'll tell you what i'm
going to do all my listeners go to dsg
or something uh go to dsgear.com right
now if there's something you like go to
dsg right now and press in joey boom and
get five [ __ ] percent off your
order okay everything is hemp quality
made i mean uh chris is a great guy i
trust him you'll get the shipping sent
to your house i mean everything's
it's tremendous i'm in love with that
stuff like i said the fanny pack of your
travel and the black jujitsu bag they're
[ __ ] phenomenal i got my knee pads in
there i got a white belt in there i got
a blue belt in there i got an extra knee
pad in there i put my wallet in there i
got two towels in there i got no spray
in there i got a canteen in there i got
a rubber thing in there and i got a
pouch of [ __ ] protein powder in there
i put my d in there i put my belt in
there i put a [ __ ] bag in there to
put the dirty rash guard in which is
sent to me by datsusara that's how
[ __ ] much they know about what you go
through with jiu jitsu not only that
they sponsor ebi so they're right there
in the [ __ ] trenches so if you're a
jiu jitsu person go to dsgear.com right
now and cut the [ __ ] [ __ ]
number two on it.com always on top of it
i got some mixed greens sent to me the
lemon lime [ __ ]
tremendous you understand me let's say
you don't want to eat your lettuce you
don't like your [ __ ] broccoli you
don't like your [ __ ] guts neither do
i this is what you go to go to honor.com
right now whether it's the hem force
protein whether it's the [ __ ] alpha
brain which is a money-back hundred
percent guarantee they don't even want
the product back whether it's the shroom
tech sport or the shroom tech immune hey
i got 10 off on you on the way out go to
the box and press in church boom i give
you 10 off that if you like the
kettlebells and the the bats and all
that stuff i can't do nothing for you
there but as far as supplements are
concerned uncle joey's got your back so
on it datsusara i want to thank you as
both again dsd ds gear
and press in joey boom and on it.com and
press in church boom there you go ten
percent off five percent off both of
them delivered to your [ __ ]
door and that's a wrap [ __ ] i want to
thank willie barcelona one more time
don't forget about the truth hurts on
[ __ ] netflix you think they put
them on netflix if he's some type of
[ __ ] half a mutt get your life
together [ __ ] lisa and have a great
weekend i love you willie barcelona
don't forget austin texas september 15th
new york city
september 24th gotham comedy club cut
the [ __ ] don't tell me later joey i was
gonna get tickets
and you put me on the list there ain't
no list i grew up in [ __ ] jersey i
got 18 people calling me up giving me
dates and [ __ ] leave me the [ __ ] alone
there's no list get the tickets today
stay black have a great week and we'll
be back monday morning for you
[ __ ] when you wake up monday
you'll have a [ __ ] brand new podcast
i love you guys stay black have a great
weekend
what do you think of that lisa you know
we don't [ __ ] around
you